I was dancing behind the camera he was
enjoying that show guy he's here dude
welcome to et laughing yes thank you I
know how does it feel to be named one of
Hollywood Reporter's rising young stars
men grateful it's wild man it took 14
years and I'm not nowhere near where I
want to be but it's just really cool to
to be honored like that we're off to a
damn good start literally like we have
so many questions for you both you are
just such an interesting person
actor human being and we want to try to
get through as many as possible and of
course if you have any fan questions you
know tweet us at ET now using the
hashtag is you live but uh let's talk
about first all first off the new film
Velle that you are going to be a part of
it kind of sounds like a baby driver
meets Mission Impossible movie you know
how will Noah the action star be
different from no rom-com um I think
it's a feeling definitely it's like a
it's like a a vibe it's a it's a it's a
mood overall like ambiance of the film
would be completely different
the tone will be completely separate and
I think that'll really really separate
them but there's you know there is love
there's romance in this and there's uh
there's there's obviously action that's
it's a really great film then I read it
and I was so passionate about it and I
just really related to it
intrinsically and I couldn't let it go
isn't that the gauze and actitude to
like spread your wings and do all kinds
of different stuff I feel like this is
just the next evolution of what you're
about to give us including I mean aren't
you also gonna be in Elizabeth Banks
Charlie's Angels reboot that's right I
mean we've got all that you mean
Elizabeth Banks not just Elizabeth Banks
film but Charlie's Angels my sister what
was your reaction
oh no I mean Ella Berlin's good Kristen
Stewart got me and I only I'm like oh my
cambot no that's not that's the next
film right
in time and it's just I don't know man
they're they're very loving people and
and as soon as I were filming in Germany
and in Turkey and as soon as I got there
they were like what's good man I was
like yeah a fish and then they just all
lovely deeply talented and dedicated
individual did you feel right at home
speaking of Elizabeth Banks she's one of
the lucky ones who has been able to
secure a follow from you on social media
you know you have over 15 million Graham
but you only follow 114 people right
right they're very diverse you know you
have zoe Kravitz you have Russell Brand
elizabeth dylan sprouse but not okay so
what is the criteria to get a follow
from you and I'm taking notes Noah if I
want to look at what you're posting on a
daily basis and it inspires me motivates
me or like moves me in some way that's
like I want to you know I'm not gonna
follow someone just because I know them
like what comes up on my timeline I want
it to be like oh that's so cool
something you're interested in care
about it's just curated to what I want
to look at you know I like to think it
could be like a gallery like I've
followed different like curators museums
or like you know internet museums if you
will that just post art and that's what
I look at so I feel like I'm in a
gallery yeah I don't want Instagram so
it's tight well you have a lot of famous
followers though people who follow you
right yeah well you you know speaking of
just social me I want to touch on this
really quick because you know obviously
your social just skyrocketed almost
overnight it's been incredible Netflix
exactly you know in speaking of the
Netflix family I was on the red carpet
at the premiere for the chilling
Adventures of Sabrina and I asked
everyone you know who their celebrity
crush was and I just I want to show you
this video you're kidding
yeah
Noah sent today Oh hit me up I'm all
yours slide into those DM he's cute he's
give on a day with him
Noah sent today oh but you don't want to
D with me
that's my favorite she said she asked if
you will go on date with her they were
not shy about that they're like God
holler at me an idea but no I was
amazing I totally fed on it though you
were like yeah what do you think about
Noah's I just said who's your celebrity
crush and H I mean it just spits out and
they're not the only ones but there's
been a few people coming on our show I
mean listen no the first time you were
here it's when everyone started calling
you the Internet's boyfriend I wanna
know like what females do you think are
rocking it like who is the Internet the
girlfriend would you say right now like
oh you got yes I'm gonna find don't you
uh you know it doesn't even be like
romantic you'd be someone who's just
crushing the game and man the next you
yeah duh yeah always
that's girl she's in fantastic man she
knows exactly what she wants and I think
she's really getting it on Charlie so I
mean Elizabeth Banks says she she posts
a lot she does she like keeps everybody
updated all they're very engaged and
that's impressive I don't think I'm even
posters like you know a consistently
engaged um zoe zoe kravitz no in crab
thank you I was like something from
fantastic beasts last big little eyes
gotta make it to that I ran into her at
this like Halloween shindig and didn't
know it was her cause her costume was so
great and and we talked for like ten
seconds
but it was super casual and just in
passing and I was like I was like that
girl she's really dope
the next day she posts her outfit but
that's actually was really cool about
the interaction was it was just
right now you know and that's gonna
happen a lot for you I think ya know is
starring in a new movie called slight
get it like a dating app ya know they're
harmless we do want to know though so
obviously in the movie you play a
college guy who comes up with a dating
app so my question for you know is which
dating apps have you tried oh I think
when I was younger I like tried the
gauntlet of them and then I just don't
use them anymore you can't you're too
famous now one for you know famous
people out here in LA that Mason Ryan
used Rio for a little while but I've
deactivated it and no it's just like for
me I'd rather meet people doing things
that I enjoy doing right you know
because then we already have
similarities between us and it's like if
I go to a yoga class
as long as I do class and like I think
she's cute we are ready or off to a
great start
yeah like yoga shared interest come on
come on like what's your favorite food
we gotta find that restaurant like that
kill shake pill shape y'all got Noah
yeah I love it are you said that your
mother's deign advice for you was wrap
it up so clearly you aren't shy when it
comes to you know opening up about your
dating life with your mom do you ever
let your mom read your DMS oh man I I
don't even really go do my DMS
verse to me like well unless it's my
friends it is my friends oh they answer
mark because my friends and I
communicate on Instagram to you
sometimes uh but no not you don't need
to see any of that but you guys have a
close bottom I doubt very close yeah she
sure like number one priority and and
and everything is just to make sure that
I have a safe place to go to if I need
and like a mom like loves me and that's
apostle she's are so proud of you your
whole family I know that
aren't you gonna it worked out because
you did ask your parents to move to LA
at a very young age right so you could
pursue this dream and it's happening
yeah man if it hadn't worked out who
knows what they still have got your back
I know that
yeah sure I gotta ask you this is one of
the questions that I know a lot of of
your fans had and some of our producers
had said before that you look for
someone who is quote honest and takes
care of themselves
yes have you found that person yet uh
yeah yeah I mean in the past I've been
very fortunate to like meet and date and
fall in love with you know two people
that I would say like fit that parameter
and yeah it's out there man yeah yeah it
is
we wouldn't know but we're like you know
we're swiping still all right so by the
way I met both of them out like doing
things you did IRL that's way to go huh
ya know when people are lucky enough to
go on a date with you what do you like
are you more of a planner do you like to
be spontaneous
would you like to plan something are you
more spontaneous spent it depends on
online the vibe like maybe I'll be like
yo we should plan to go bungee jumping
and another like no casual date but that
kind of just happened and they're like
that's like pretty except we're not
gonna go but every night this is not
gonna work out or sometimes it's just
like it's like you meet someone and
you're like what are you doing right now
mm they're like I don't really have
anything you're like come on go hang out
let's go through someone's get coffee
it's like okay now do you pick up the
tab or do you split it I usually pick it
up not because I don't think that like
they can't pay I just I just like
picking it up yeah it's one I think it's
one of my love languages like providing
taken care of and not having someone
else have to worry about something that
ship Arisa
we appreciate right you're welcome we
went to last week change the subject
really quick we have a photo of you you
were recently on an episode of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians so it made us
wonder would you ever do a reality
series has that been some
thing that you've been approached with
enough for a while hmm
I'm not really interested in that I
think maybe if I did it'd be like when I
was way older right now it's the focus
isn't acting career huh yeah yeah you
actually the last time you were here
told us that you would be so down to
play a villain so much in fact that you
would like shave off your hair would you
ever want to be like a superhero you
know as you mentioned that I'm like
thinking you know everyone's compare you
to Mark Ruffalo you could be a young
Hulk in the prequel yeah I would I would
I would be so happy right to be a young
Hulk yes I cannot even like explain to
you that would be so dope he was my
favorite
yeah like Marvel hero yeah yeah and the
fact that Mark Ruffalo plays yeah has
mark ever have you guys ever been in
contact I know I've asked you this
before because you were just like the
spitting image of him you sound like him
no do you think he it's early we're
seeing all these things out loud so we
can manifest well we want to toss it
over to our container to there pal no
one's here I mean we haven't either
we have execs who are here too were just
like you know we want to come hang out
would know it well I do appreciate you
being here man swipes are used to not
attention yet no no oh man it's still
like a it still happens it's like people
who like come up and I'm like I has been
kind of the craziest fan reaction you've
experienced so far Oh
besides our control room I don't know
that I've had I had some people meet me
at the airport when I was flying into
New York but since then we made amends
and like it's all love sometimes people
just will scream just scream just ain't
allowed cuz you're so chilled by you
know hey why you got to scream everybody
gonna look like they're gonna be like
what's that guy doing to that girl like
you know it's like
I'm just standing here hey but I have
noticed that you do stop and take that
selfie though that's what makes you so
great well you know I'm so good with
this fans in our break and our
commercial break he did record a video
for and that was fairly dying young fan
about Yomi Manuel thanks again for being
here appreciate you being so chill and
awesome congratulations on swipe tan we
can't wait for the next slate of films
coming your way man
[Music]
[Applause]